Pollen is practically indestructible, and
it’s everywhere in everything
But it’s also tiny, and unless you
have seasonal allergies,
you probably barely notice it
But 100 years ago, Lennart von Post
realized that these
tiny plant particles have a
huge story to tell
The compound that makes up pollen’s tough
shell,
called sporopollenin, is
practically indestructible.
It’s so stable that pollen from
310 million years ago
can be analyzed for its
chemical similarity to pollen today,
and ancient pollen provides some
of the earliest evidence for land plants,
preserving an evolutionary
record of plant life
Studying preserved pollen can tell us what
kind of plants grew in a place.
That, in turn, tells us what
the climate must have been like
and how it has changed over time.
Through radiocarbon dating,
pollen can tell
us how old a site is
Pollen preserved in the dung of predators
can tell us what they ate and what their prey was
As molecular techniques improve, ancient DNA
and biological molecules from pollen
will provide a wealth of new information,
enough to keep pollen scientists
busy for another 100 years